sky news can confirm that uh suela
bravaman is going to back liz truss in
the next round of voting for the
conservative party leadership now in
terms of the mathematics uh
sweller bravaman polled 27 votes um
it's not uh clear that all of those will
go to liz trust if they did i mean liz
trust got 64. if they all went so that
would be 91 and that would take her
ahead of penny morden but it's thought
that probably only about half of zweller
bravaman's votes will go to liz truss um
perhaps taking a sort of neck and neck
all there abouts uh with uh penny
mordant steve baker one of her leading
lieutenants said he would do whatever
sweller braverman decides to do um so
that is the breaking news after the vote
uh this afternoon suella bravaman who
polled 27 votes and dropped out is
saying that she is going to back liz
trust the foreign secretary in the next
round now
mps i was talking to today were talking
about the need for deals uh on brexit uh
perhaps a pledge to a pull out of the
european court of human rights uh we
hope to speak to uh suella bravaman
again very shortly find out if she's
spoken to liz trust what deals if any
have been done i'm sure she'll pledge no
deals but uh that's what the candidates
always say isn't it